you probably already know that
everything is made up of little tiny
things called atoms
you might even know that each atom is
made up of even smaller particles called
protons neutrons and electrons and
you've probably heard that atoms are
small but oh but you haven't ever
thought about how small atoms really are
well the answer is that they are really
really really small so so you ask just
how small are atoms well to understand
this let's ask this question how many
atoms are in a grapefruit well let's
assume that the grapefruit is made up of
only nitrogen atoms which isn't at all
true
but there are nitrogen atoms in a
grapefruit well to help you visualize
this let's blow up each of the atoms to
the size of a blueberry and then how big
would the grapefruit have to be you
would have to be the same size Oh
actually the earth that's crazy
you can just say that if I filled the
earth with blueberries I would have the
same number of nitrogen atoms as a
grapefruit that's right so how BIG's
them
that's a really really really really
small and you know what it gets even
more crazy let's now look inside of each
atom and that's the blueberry right what
do you see there
in the center of the atom is something
called the nucleus which contains
protons and neutrons and on the outside
you'd see electrons so how big is the
nucleus
well if atoms are like blueberries in
the earth how big with the nucleus be
you might remember the old pictures of
the atom from your science class where
you saw this tiny dot on the page with
an arrow pointing to the nucleus well
those pictures well they're not drawn to
scale so they're they're kind of wrong
so how big is the nucleus so if you
popped open the blueberry and we're
searching for the nucleus you know what
it would be invisible it's too small to
see okay let's blow up the atom the
blueberry to the size of a house so
imagine a ball that is as tall as its
two-story house let's look for the
nucleus in the center of the atom and
you know what it would just barely be
visible so to get our minds wrapped
around how big the nucleus is we need to
blow up the blueberry up to the size of
a football stadium so imagine a ball the
size of a football stadium
smack-dab in the center of the atom you
would find the nucleus and you could see
it and it would be the size of a small
marble and there's more if I haven't
blown your mind by now let's consider
the atoms immortal it contains protons
neutrons and electrons the protons and
neutrons live inside of the nucleus and
contain almost all of the mass of the
atom weigh on the edge are the electrons
so if an atom is like a ball the size of
a football stadium with a nucleus in the
center and the electrons on the edge
what is in between the nucleus and the
electrons surprisingly the answer is
empty space that's right empty between
the nucleus and the electrons there are
vast regions of empty space now
technically there are some
electromagnetic fields but in terms of
stuff matter is empty remember this vast
region of empty space is inside the
blueberry which is inside the earth
which truly are the atoms in the
grapefruit ok one more thing if I can
even get more bizarre since virtually
all the mass of an atom is in the
nucleus and now there is some amount of
mass in the electrons but most of it is
in the nucleus how dense is the nucleus
well the answer is crazy
the density of a typical nucleus is 4
times 10 to the 17th kilogram per meter
cube but that's hard to visualize ok
I'll put it in English units 2.5 times
10 to the 16th pounds per cubic feet
ok that's still kind of hard to figure
ok here's what I want you to do make a
box that is 1 foot by 1 foot by 1 foot
now let's go and grab all of the nuclei
from a typical car now cars on average
weigh two tons
how many cars is nuclei would you have
to put into the box to have your 1 foot
box have the same density of nucleus is
it one car - how about 100 nope nope and
nope the answer is much bigger it is 6.2
billion that is almost equal to the
number of people in the earth so if
everyone on the earth owned their own
car and they don't
we put all of those cars into your box
that would be about the density of a
nucleus so I'm saying that it can't look
every car in the world and put it in
your 1 foot box it would have the
density of 1 nucleus ok let's review the
atom is really really really small think
atoms in a grape fruit like blueberries
in the earth the nucleus is crazy small
now look inside the blueberry and blow
it up to the size of a football stadium
and now the nucleus is a marble in the
middle the atom is made up of vast
regions of empty space that's where the
nucleus has a crazy high density think
I'm putting all those cars in your 1
foot box I think I'm tired